[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast its
podcast tick Network and this is one
I've been waiting for for a while since
e3 I want to shout out a clear to forge
games and obviously the good friends at
what you call entertainment these guys
with Shepherd entertainment liked on
that whatever but oh yeah man this is
something I've had my eye on for a while
phantom doctrine and I'm ready to get
into this thing definitely in the realm
of X comma s peonage all that good stuff
I'm a huge Xbox fan base that seems to
have a nice little twist on it so
without further ado let's get into the
statement
[Music]
did I break this together
seed options real quick now for my
speaking with the deaf again if you
haven't checked it out please vote on
the podcast channel actually to John
because we actually had a good interview
the Deveny did say that there was always
death the best movies um they did say
that this would be Xbox one and X in
Abel so I'm not sure right now because
when I did the install you know I did
not get a chance to see that in that
list so all yeah that's not there right
now so maybe because it's what had ahead
of time they got a later date they were
added but again fans of XCOM fans of
that term based tactical this might be
something you want to look into so we
will get this thing started man
all right so we got regular mold easy
medium
alright so easy to new to turn base
that's not me
so let's get medium what see go see
where all this hard is ramp the
difficulty for those seeking extra
challenge body disposal unavailable we
go to our tutorial which I would need
Ironman mode nice to see that X behavior
people love that Hawk board you got your
subtitles nice let's get this thing
going
alright so you can do your background
set up so you can be CIA or KGB corny
deadpan Allah Allah
then we got a KGB hunt traitors at the
motherland how do you decorate occasion
honor intelligence operations
so let's start with CIA
really
got to keep the board
[Music]
see already they start with a lot of
customization it seems
rather the like John's over here of a
roll of exam I'm gonna Josh some guy did
some small problem here I like it
I feel like this move oh okay checking
it out check it at all this might be the
guy right here it's kind of kind of
close to [ __ ]
love the picture at all this might be
amp right here it's my
like me too
I like this
the little car to get the fast shirt I
think it's
so we're gonna press next to eight oh
you really could get the customization I
like that that's something next XCOM
fans like you don't really want to feel
attached to these characters I have
preset faces you guys stuff I press it
in left animal oh okay you got your skin
color got you pressing right yeah
[Music]
set face now do we have any hair
customization I see we got body tight
slap stocky athletic
come on come on now we got to get with
it muscles build muscle dudes I guess
I'm at the world with athletic right now
it's the creative force baby you gotta
look out for the guys that hit the
weights that lift
Oh
[Music]
it seems that hey I would love to be
able to change deflation oh I'm an idiot
love if I press was it right trigger
okay then beatnik slicked-back it made
it kind of a lot of customers all we
could take his bag
keep it
really
I need copies the little half goat seen
with a mustache we got half goatee with
a mustache it might be a girl oh so
patch that might be a goal
so practice looking but it's going to be
I don't like here the boys just wrap
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah we're gonna have to go to
so fetch
gotta get my arm
like that
actually you got too close to see what
the options are all would keep real
professional office my Colombo
sure okay
and expect this amount of customization
I think we might have p.m. I have to
keep it keep it a little corporate keep
it smooth aggravated it's
yeah I'd be part of the corn poor man
you gotta confess to me I'm I keep this
this distant
[Music]
yeah I think I would be really on my
espionage and chair
really want to get the Myrtle home
[Music]
knocks words let's keep ox chains of
color
[Music]
head oh if they got me a little fedora
I might it might be go oh man
yeah feeling like if I grow up in five
and a desk
[Music]
or you know you can do strike okay well
that's the hair that the Hat comes with
here okay whatever
you can see that coming I guess that's
me for right now and I forgot a way to
take that book gently
from all that why do I have here with a
fedora
okay that part you gotta explain
whatever
I await them if they got a model
for Shannon
aba this oh my my rocket eyepatch look
at that hair off doing that
why does my fedora have hair let's take
this
that is so weird fedoras come with head
right why is that this is I just don't
want head oh can I take the hair
it comes with here okay we found
something death that's not okay
egg is good Detailers scars
enough of this blow hit max I guess
start this to save and why is - so we
gonna get into it see about this
everything carried out those which
basically it's having the opposite
evening hurdle verifies own risk trust
no one
[Music]
videochat oh listen a lot of ball headed
god
here is called Yankee Juliet uniform
reporting contraband seized understood
break off patrol head back to base the
body HMS Conqueror Naru shall about the
Oman channel we got Intel from
Vladivostok it's big Steve Langley seen
it yet no should they
hey oh yeah but use the network we don't
want anyone listening in first the
British ends now the Americans is there
anyone else you wanted to involve in our
plans point of view your incompetence
has exposed us now iceberg is in
jeopardy doing all of this in the open
was your idea
true it was a simple plan that any fool
could have executed and you failed
gentlemen this problem is easily solved
now now don't shout it's bad for your
heart
organization
Stingley chose to go it's still supposed
to video alright tutorial so we got a
top secret okay objectives reached a
sleeper agent activate his control
phrase steel shipping manifests execute
on the other side of the border no
secondary objectives operation threshold
east-berlin high-value cargo hijacked by
the British agent kingfish to redeploy
in the UK run recovery ops to phase 1
and to the British sector collect forms
from a secure location activate sleeper
asset look further orders to be
disclosed in due course and the handler
is Valhalla so yeah we just see what
this thing is about and I definitely
will speak to dev as far as the Xbox 1x
enhancer because I did get confirmation
when I speaking to Devon e3 that these
this game would be Xbox one X in hand so
just curious about that again we
definitely want the highest infidelity
I hope you have a good reason for
pulling me off that RAF gig absolutely
this operation is crucial to project
iceberg why are you even talking to me
you're taking an awful risk nonsense
they may be expecting defectors but not
the kind of hardware you're carrying you
look up you look good
okay
and raises a little rough there locator
chip indicates the sleeper is in a
position are you familiar with okay yeah
the infiltration of stage guards will
only react if you do something
suspicious to the indicated position so
definite looks like an Eskimo soccer or
for people to players who played asked
me to stay inside this area you don't
use a lot of action points but this
looks like they want me to go outside
this area which might ways to turn sorry
[Music]
the adverse effects on
yep just I got door so most actions cost
action points some action is especially
combat-related course fire ones that's
the red okay
found doctors turn basin when all your
agents points are depleted that ends
your turn okay so pretty much the same
basic tried and true XCOM give so
movement use a excel in your turn
and u-turn I'm assuming is
the select okay got it
the activities there turn ok be careful
when entering restricted air at the red
zone if the guard sees you they'll call
your mom all right stay with him
into what
okay skip the next turn and the God will
continue in his patrol it move the
cursor over character to preview their
patrol path
so I guess yes I'm pretty much this is
what he's delivering okay got it so you
can get like a heads up where they
interesting
with this agent dead man of FiOS spoke
about
the latest CIA a washout could be
dangerous
okay when in a recessionary merely with
the caution
use R to rotate camera [ __ ] beans
which we have done
[Music]
yeah
it looks like just also they give you a
trespassing state okay so void cameras
they will trigger the alarm if you come
across their cone of vision okay so this
is obviously our camera right here so
cameras can be disabled if you find a CC
TV central okay okay
[Music]
I guess that's been sitting on there
recipe I don't know why it's not know
that doing it
hmm
interesting good Oh X I see that's a
faith back state yeah they need to get
that eliminated a bit more but I did not
see that
deal with the security quietly we don't
want unnecessary trouble I think I can
in turn
yes guys it's like hitman the next time
you got you know the spy aspect which is
different from an ex Colombians
interesting definitely reasons why it
appealed to me
right so I got one more action point now
they want me to go here into the main
building now there's a guy there
that's interesting
but for the second tutorial we're gonna
do it
give him the control phrase all right
enemy agent Logan is one of our sleeper
agent used to control phase from the up
abilities but you now that right trigger
okay so take control over an enemy
subjected to control phase a sleepers 82
safe to go anywhere go up the stairs use
the dimensional turn up to go up floors
in selected target
so when I used to control phase the heat
down would describe like okay if we got
but if it lazy guard all right up there
K which is here Jesus he was a sleeper
agent and basically just took control up
the steps interesting
laws can be taken now silently provided
that HP is more than that of the
attacker he is HP
aha that's a third file okay so
right okay
so right sugar seems to be a lot of
their action controls a little different
in that respect
suddenly incapacitates the target HP is
lower than the attack okay engage it not
only need to look at someplace get that
goal
all characters have a certain level of
awareness is used by selecting actions
I met awareness flowers it's a dodge
shot at effectively reducing your seat
damage awareness regenerates every turn
okay
all right so
[Music]
or I used a spotter to lift the fog up
or reveal enemies and civilians inside
the indicated moon built that support
agents operate from a specific direction
it must have line of sight for the
target to be effective so we're gonna
press that right through there
this is a spotter reveals the fog of war
with and select the area makes it harder
for enemies and ladies to dodge it nice
so you kind of like pre-state but who
clear before you ready to clear it out
if it's beef or if you just want to kind
of see
press confirm to use it
but it's not working oh I'm gonna have
to put over the target aha
right
interesting
oh here we go
[Music]
make sure takes a little bit easier Loki
gives you documents we'll have to breach
the room don't worry I'll clean the mess
entry so basically what it seems that
just opened up okay our spotter
basically opened up what was in it one
which is two guards place your agents at
the door to breach attack okay so I
literally it's like a sniper like a
snitch I got looking for me
[Music]
okay so we've got a place your agents
have to do okay that's my original guy
but I came in here with
[Music]
okay
selected for each ability and select the
module for attack and confront reach
confers a damage bonus making it extra
deadly so right trigger there's a breach
option
[Music]
Westray triggers that in
No
seems like don't think I don't like this
not like a black a back button
yeah ank I'm actually playing banner
saga now anchored it's really go switch
yeah I do like it yep that's my made
is it
back off let's frigate backs Network
be ok
it's got to get these controls
okay bring on enemies to lock them as
targets hmm okay left trigger okay
but why are they not locking mr. Bush
I'm gonna hit I don't think this is
accurate
okay note that using non suppressed
weapons always triggers along and starts
combat in turn yeah I don't know if I
did that right he along with raised
unsuppressed gun has been fired
[Music]
there's our external
[Music]
that's the country
I'm getting note add to the evac zone
the driver will take you directly to
summon that video they could get away
car
okay evac will take to terms of roughs
that set up or watched it go little
action we gonna set up overwatch to
guard the rule set up a garden area
[Music]
yes
left trip
I'm sure
action
pressing left ring another example
oh maybe direction of I'm still a little
bathroom this control
placed it pressing left right depressing
me not happening
why could I do this action get back on
the character better sure
correction nothing
[Music]
question
yep stop don't know what I did wrong
stuck
[Music]
but no oh my god
interest
good old controls I guess
would do some a trusty pup can't save
and made
you know yeah I'm trying to walk there
ain't gonna but it's like it's not you
know it's not funny
Canty was switched to the turn sorry
let's meet it again vac we'll take two
turns to arrive set up over watched
guard
they don't even let me
and then what screaming at me in the
bottom left is lecture and I'm pressing
up sugar not that okay
maybe was left trigger and then
directional path
then I will prove here
got to figure out that little snafu now
we can set up overwatch
[Music]
right set up overwatch outside note that
long-range overwatch has a conical
effect as opposed a circular short-range
overwash okay
what am I supposed to tell ya Oh
why maybe it's the water
[Music]
nice okay Oh school watch boys a favor
jump out with Joe and a couple know that
dad on watching
[Music]
actually
all the time which was suppressed to
enemy practically removing their
awareness okay all we got the little
close up now that's how I like this is
that calm I like sinister what's going
on man okay so we got phantom Josh moon
has no random chance to hit but a task
can deal various amount of damage
presenters problems targets by
automatically dodging incoming attacks
divided they are nine point blank range
dodging course awareness so where this
is key in this game detected damage
okay all right so they've got different
low attribute points everything kind of
has its purpose so now we got a move to
the ground level
- color which looks like his truck
you gotta jump to the window get a pop
okay some weapons are acting up to land
devastating headshots was that cool five
okay so far
Oh Edith Wars cover protection as the
target
X
ah
[Music]
still kind of got to get to the drop oh
no the trap just came but he did send
jobs coming in to turn my bad my bad as
synesthete he stole from desktop sue
them no they stole from ex-con that's
good that's good that's what we want to
do we want to follow
ideas the projected complete
be a little slowly active that's why I'm
very curious about this on the X see how
much the different staff ladies so now
is a little first joint
get with me Oh
[Music]
exactly you see what happened with what
I borrowed we go to one mission before
we finish up this preview but you're so
far so good basic premise I like
controls a little clunky we got to get
get some issues where I don't feel they
respect a person who's not playing any
XCOM games before I could see some
confusion in especially I'm an ex-con
vet so there was some things that weird
but despite aspect the atmosphere
very very cool I want to attempt one
mission and then we'll call the Lord of
preview over with unsanctioned read the
project evacuate upon completion of main
objective secondary objectives
six weeks earlier
you really think this Pakistani nuclear
program is legit Leslie's usually right
about these things really [ __ ] been 10
bucks it wasn't you're a hopeless
dreamer pulled
ah this looks familiar actually uh this
level actually displayed first time I
think I've seen the game and again at e3
tried to a good shot and I plan a spot
that a nice sell hitter to call every
year this was the how I saw the game for
the story time kinda like this get off
the bag and it looks like we got
multiple agents that's kind of nice
stuff let's go girl
okay so when agent is disguised they can
safely go anywhere without lazing along
suspicious actions witnessed by enemies
as Liz will trigger combat and if he
agents always seek with the sky
I get a chance to really analyze these
guys that's what I wanted okay so look
like toggle character details ok deadpan
he's got empath upon healing other
characters this character also restores
a small amount of HP status effect
disguise approaches loyal is low agent
oil and impervious to enemy influence
main character is your main cast my do
right there okay let's check out the
rain
I pain stimulus when hit this agent
receives a bonus to damage from the
firewalls status affect the skies we
know all right Dan a home girl cannot
stop now passive ability opportunists
unbanning
bonus damage against suppressed
characters and then she's also discussed
those ought to read you get my mains
dead pain were sentenced I'm with you
man I like this which I yeah I need I
need this on switch so see if we could
take a look at
this is where we gotta be it seems which
the sealed-off area
typical XCOM fashion check these out
[Music]
yes and another thing is this again
speech the Devlin is this is supposed to
be Xbox accident case so that's what I
was told then maybe the assets weren't
ready this window needs to gain but I'm
definitely definite
for the Xbox one exit acids so we
disguise so technically we should be
able to do we want to do
I'm just saying I know Sam I mean I'm
sending a train see what's up I'm gonna
put it next to that
press Wow
now he still heard does he have any more
actually his turn is done we went past
that yeah I'm looking for overwatch but
I think because I went past mine oh he
can attack oh there's oh oh oh so that's
overwatch that's okay so I messed up I
went outside to turn should have just
chill it's gonna strike next guys just
go to mommy oh the damn pain this is
okay old school XCOM stay within my
action points roll out here
okay now
you're not gonna we ain't gonna kill
nobody be still in disguise oh I set up
a guardian and English crossing this
area we shot I'm not ready to shoot
nobody
yeah so we just got sure there's good
show and we're gonna move our home girl
Kai Master I like that name okay I'm a
mover super for I want your heart
position oh she can move oh I like she
crazy
this is where we gotta pee
laser barriers there's definitely
something valuable get rid of them
before you scroll through one remains a
parable about that see something yeah
all this might be to shut down a laser
barrier okay so looks like everybody's
got action
deadpan got action points Canasta has
though she's out so Oh Deb hand come on
right I hear Elmo Cabo
good answer
we in the sky so it should be no beef
deadpans the closest
claps XCOM y'all I like the spa thing
that's hot
alright he's out
position she's gonna be close to most
I'm gonna get him a stack right here
Jason go left
each to seal off area and the objectives
to save me the laser valuation option
canastas ready
she should be able to go in there
guiding old lowlife son
out
okay that's cool so when you put the
thing on the floor so you totally did so
that's it wants to be lazy so she has
one so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
get behind home
and then we should be able to get to up
then take down okay all these just
different people okay that's on the map
of that guy's farm
you could stabilize us let's pick up an
Asian take down anyone what's this
extortion exertion improve the movement
ranges character by two okay so when you
really want to bounce you can use that
so let's go to take down fast on the
mold
she's a step-over okay
he's out of action games yelling at me
everybody must be out of action coins
see if he can he can't he does about
action for me so I can't do no more so
yes it's the hassanchop
we got it disable that area
interesting two action points if I go
there looks like I'll be alerted both of
these are two action point actions but
technically justice guys I don't know
what the issue
I'm not going to do that I just don't
sure then I guess curious about what's
behind why he had the bus through the
window
thousand
yeah it's clearly a mistake
to go left look for him or watch is the
case
so
anybody
can't do it
there's nothing to confirm
I don't want to attack
let's see what else is there
she's got it
see the rest
actually I'm off
let me put him a little maybe because
it's not a damage for yourself
okay so now what is just on the things
don't know how I get that I'm gonna pick
that up
it's
factors
this is interesting
focus or say
I should be able it looks like there's
something here to pick up and I cannot
pick this mmm
okay
Oh X there it is damn X
classified
nice get a spy
stack up deadpan gonna have to get that
for
he can't go to me okay
deadpan is out of action
shoot
fact 1 in sack
[Music]
for whatever reason you can't overwatch
in the infiltration I think that's just
what this
okay I thought this is gonna go left in
here they don't mind me busting through
the window
I'm here
so we got classified Docs here and I
gotta get it this dude is in the way
this is a once earned okay so I might be
able to do it okay I want that
classified doctor so we going through
the hassanchop misery
a SAN Punk this character
I am
controls a difference than that exactly
I probably got to be exactly in front of
it
but because I wasted months that
can't go in there
i'ma get him over just in case we get
crazy
now definitely have to hand itself
people have the weapon so I'm sure
haven't shown but I can't have him watch
was this
frag grenade okay
right
speech you gotta think I says she can't
he can't write so we just got to close
the master
Wow oh so he's sorry okay got it
so he saw the body that knocking go XCOM
you are this yes felt like he we are now
in it's on and poppin most broken
filtration then we will take down on
now supposed to be a little boy slow I
don't want to kill homie
so they probably snitched already and
these are probably nonviolent Bieber so
you know made no sense at this point
forget it doctors that's not always -
Turner's this one services - terms also
you know what I'm a one turn and
overwatch effect I'm overwatch right
here
they still not let me pick it though is
that no control why is that don't know
gotta figure it out
I see of the homie alright he can attack
set it up for our enemies across and I
don't like that I can't set up my own
watch right now I don't know why I can
attack
yeah that's right why is that cost I
guess it's one
that is you
salute you I don't know why I can't all
watch
all day [ __ ] is just ease now no wash
my steady hitting them behind a wall
about enemy action
the scientist is paté out they switched
me out
yes we killing get out over what
this one's red so I guess it's not a
good shot then we attack single attack
full portal it suppresses them and
regeneration shot I wish I had like some
accuracy numbers
attacked first this is one course 14.4
by a consent with a precise birds
confirmed damage of text length
oh okay
and I still get away
so we gonna do
reckless masu happens oh alright
jump up it for like bumper bonuses you
know I'm saying like if they've good
enough to hit what's the percentage of
the shot landing kind of stuff I'm not
really really seeing that
so that I would like
I trust this example
Berry is down what I guess it's just
like an escape area let's get her
Oh so on the poppin
got a lot of background noise
must entail my topknot a million-dollar
yacht this is been exposed to water
well we're looking for the reactor no
luck it traces everywhere
she's got one
45 we got another one here
we're on different shots
she could only shoot more time
so first does 17 7 and 15
scares about full-auto first
a suppressor
so it's their turn now so long now
damn he opened this game
he came out the x-rays
this is
oh oh oh that's that's stuck as if
you're playing
Oh chance she getting the business she
might all she might not survive is she's
getting the business
yeah did wait this is set up really
stone-faced I'm here oh man it's going
left go left
you got a man right here he's got 45
we're really doing that
that's the two action points oh don't
make no sense so you go get back to
killing
raise them
yeah all right he's got to help her out
she's getting the business but damn
that's to action 20 just a little bit
but he got to shoot from back here
assault rifles dude who could he get
only to get flanked oh so I'm not
getting hit him first
yes get him first
that's 26
he can use espero oh this French shoots
a 53 focus damage that's what she needs
she was focused oh he got the frag dad I
should have moved on sinister this is
not XCOM you were missing everything
that is I gotta get him in there to help
that out all right
what not only sir so switched it act on
those exactly
that French whatever that is 50 please
get them
great Komal fan you can't be crazy
just stop the table for that eagle walk
we gotta get him out of it okay you go
again
you list the hassanchop yeah get up
so I don't have enough fire points for
that
Gregg radius knocking
he's got he doesn't have okay he cannot
shoot he gotta get behind
chill out
she's magic
she's got 18
they see $45.99 oh this is the problem I
hate let's see you know what car would
do you up close a person who see what
that do
we got attacked first you can't hold her
like a king
like you can't even if I put
purser on you know what we gonna go we
gonna see if we got test accuracy right
now to the face oh the damage numbers
went up okay I like that so based on
proximity is how you're gonna see how
much damage a single burst she could do
70 maybe that's overkill 28 no get the
job number ataxia listen all right
better than XCOM already turns over yeah
get yelling at me
she's gonna still get it though she's a
big trouble all right my man over there
deadpan hold it down
Oh - seven Danny got hit you got hit
I'll do that that's what that whole this
way it might be over
oh my via wrapkin eases out of here damn
girl
yeah
maybe who
oh they're not dead they just enter a
critical state stabilize the agent and
carry them out the Messiah we won't
venture come on let's get it you got to
get in there that is you got to save the
day we still got the two agents over
here at this point I don't think I
should be playing with the part that's
not good cover
last night
this is better company this is what he
need to be so you can get in the mix
he's food since then we started gig
all right oh we got him dead to rights
right here dead 49 damage one shot
active courses go V yeah
get that body you got get to the body
we can't even kick that for so he just
not to show by the door that's gonna
waste its action point at least he'd be
cover I still gotta figure out
overwatch man want to get over watch
popping I don't know how to oh my oh oh
she's got four turns before you can get
it okay he's got another
oh okay
either on well we can attack or we don't
have enough see this is where it should
be some overwatch joint on
do it with so good set up a garden area
enemies crossing this area will be shot
but you can't you
he don't think it's the shop now
since we the game has to be a little bit
more clear and act act let me know what
can actually be done all reinforcements
arriving all share
get frustrated - they can't get me
something he throwing up in it hi shoot
me through that wall
I'm not feeling that
dodj
of course with wonder how many turns
all right dip in let's go get off girl
she gone
oh it's deadpan I'm gonna go first
he got it so over here I can crazy so
he's just gotta get you can't go down
but he can get here that's good
he's out of action points nothing
oh shoot
not enough ammo okay so maybe he just
got a little old and he can reload and
they got another accident got first a
all plus one he could use that
check out some first aid oh that boy hit
the shot let's go
got its money shot we still have some of
that other gun that I like yeah but not
a good shot you do the frag so you gonna
get him just close to the body
girl
in Canasta
what's he doing
okay don't Lodi doing
you go for headshots let's go okay he's
pretty much done
oh oh here it is focus takedown parking
sensor reveals area and without having a
lot of sight to them he's got a lot of
ability to take he's got the takedown
there okay
sorry look at that ability I'll pick up
a Z but he doesn't have the action
points got it
focus can you generate this
characteristic where this boy damage
helps okay and let's try that
don't bother
it's not looking good - five
oh poor people comment
it ain't
yeah
he go we got to reload for us
he's like
he's just that's just a situation he's
got a lot to do
Otto
and live site
raise damn
but focus
why should he use stabilizer for her
pick up age
take so abilities is probably to take
that I'm just character for generation
yeah he don't need that what he returned
last you turned gay easily shot act like
crazy
know how you can study are they after
Oh
good thing I put that up bility on
oh boy
I can't do that with that can't
that ability you can stabilize her now
the fashion points to get over there
okay
so I did have the ability to take down I
just didn't eat that okay he's gonna
have to just shoot equipment smoke
you can only throw it here you know what
let's give her some smoke
all the attack your agents okay
how do I see this is nothing no target
one
doesn't whatever you smoke overwatch key
music
whatever reach
it's gonna have to focus again
let's go to the homie let's get his
abilities going doesn't have enough ammo
you can do that 16 killed but she's
gonna be out we've got to pick her up
move down and stabilize vent them from
bleeding out
target konista you can pick up and I'll
carry them around if that's after for
the about we got to stop up from the
about last of evening
stay at last
he what can he
it doesn't have the action points to
fire
and pull down
you really can't do anything so
this guy's just shelling
oh-o-oh eat nice
interesting the people who are out of
sight yet it means they were out of
psychic
interesting you can affect a little
possibly kill
these users right behind me
yeah we got a morning first I don't like
setup
Isis get him here
17 damage a little more damage from this
position see if you can get the article
nice
Rand
still gotta get the killing on
he's got a real old
not no yeah
I think you can only do overwatch from
maybe it's from up yes it says ten
course is one action well okay so maybe
because okay right now we don't have the
actual maybe it's the bullet count
that's probably okay
I can't right now
partly senator Beall enemies in the area
having a lot of sight
he's got a lot of nice abilities putting
that priority he can't do it
it is with us
oh-oh-oh I'm lucky this guy's trash
get very lucky there's a lot of XCOM
luck going on right here phantom - I'll
take it
I think it's not looking good though
all they got Jackson is might be a wrap
it ain't looking good anybody
even bad so he goes into action points
to action it's not in anyone's line of
sight so that ain't what if I over watch
you cannot overwatch me now yes
no we've got the bullets don't
you're not good don't know why whatever
he's seasoned a mess he's a nice I guess
at this point we just don't go duck
whole foot the objective really nothing
else we can do
he can't do much of anything
no one's in the line of sight
he screws
laughs
nice
should be a blowhole e20 not a good shot
send them so he's really not in a good
position [ __ ] semi damage can do that
we
let's just start the execution
I'm just gonna get pulled with it at
this point what else do we have to lose
oh they're right yeah you doing this
step for whatever we got a good him cuz
he's out in the open get the murder
going out plays a chord sit missions
Ovitz could compromise you're not taking
us a lot
Elizabeth
kid actions of nutty cities it's one hit
here come the exit god it's bad
he's getting a perfect shot de Lima man
of always the bomb
and Domitian Ange you have been killed
don't what the stuff over there alright
yeah we could probably get ready here
man
shout out to phantom dachshund man this
is definitely definitely shout to your
Good Shepard entertainment my good
friends over there coal Forge games
definitely like the vibe definite like
the Cold War aspect of it
XCOM fans would be right at home but
there's a lot more depth to it
again I just got to figure out that
overweight watch mechanic I don't know
if it's just me or something I didn't
pay attention to you know but overall
like I said it's a great tactical
turn-based spy game I love the
atmosphere love what's going on with it
but again they're awesome faults they
they have to get the control scheme a
little tighter I feel things we're not
easily found so that's something they
definitely have to work on and um you
know to tutorial again assumes you've
played these type of games and for a
person who's new they they might be
overwhelmed and maybe something like
icons can be a little bit more
illuminated as far as like deal you know
just picking up items and stuff I felt
it was a little cumbersome that kind of
stuff but overall I still like the game
you know and maybe as see how far the
story gets I want to see if that kind of
influence you know they're going for the
whole still images thing where I'm more
like a animation guy or video
likes to storytelling but still I like
it I like it man
so I definitely XCOM guys pick up if
you're not that kind of a person you're
not that into the game but those games
what you like kind of like Cold War kind
of stuff and ask me a knowledge of spy
you still might like it too so that's
what Cognito here I in law podcast pu /
first look fandom doctrine is out here
in the streets Xbox one and hopefully we
will get some Xbox 1x enhancements
everybody enjoy a day
[Music]